on se dope les raisins rouges l'avancé
mais quand même des balises comme ça
dans la journée qui sont rassurants
comme tous les enfants de leur âge
gaël 12 ans et sa soeur maxime 10 ans
doivent désormais s'occuper à la maison
et des casse tête un peu vers la
peinture des bricolages ou lire des
livres pour leurs parents habitués à
travailler de chez eux
c'est le temps de l'adaptation vendredi
on était encore dans le mode à les
écoles sont fermées mais on peut appeler
les cousins et on peut voir les amis qui
de jour en jour on se dit ah ben non
finalement on va couper les pompiers on
va faire comme tout le monde on va enfin
devoir des citoyens ici pour ne pas
déranger leurs parents qui travaillent
en bas les enfants les textes cela fait
partie des règles
ils sont anxieux et surtout sur le fait
que comment est ce qu'ils vont s'occuper
comment est ce qu'ils vont trouver des
activités à faire pour passer le temps
pour les parents il ya bien sûr la
tentation des écrans pour occuper les
enfants
oui c'est important de garder les
interactions sociales mais en même temps
je parce qu'on veut traverser une
période où les écrans vont sauver notre
vie autant depuis les diaboliser je
pense qu'il faut quand même faire
attention de pas laisser l'enfant
toujours toute la journée là dessus les
écrans ça peut permettre de se divertir
de s'amuser ça peut permettre aussi
d'être en contact avec ceux qu'on aime
qu'on peut pas voir en chair et en os on
avait des temps d'écran après une heure
il ya une alarme qui sonne
nous on voit aussi sur nos appareils
avec une période de congés scolaires qui
pourrait durer plus longtemps que les
deux semaines prévues
les familles vont devoir s'ajuster à
cette nouvelle réalité
la routine va s'installer d'une manière
qui va peut-être leur semble et
ennuyante
donc ça va être important ce moment là
de temps en temps de faire une espèce de
petit conseil de famille puisque on
pourrait essayer de faire une espèce de
remue méninges pour trouver des
nouvelles dès qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
pour se désennuyer pour socialiser
l'important c'est de garder leur donne
équilibre si les enfants reçoivent pas
leur dose quotidienne d'attention
positive mais ils vont nous voir un peu
comme une console l'enregistrement avec
plein de boutons puis ont essayé tous
les boutons pour ainsi d'obtenir cette
attention le plus des foyers mon appui
sur les mauvais c'est pour ça que c'est
important de le planifier dans la
journée de budgéter ce temps là pour
avoir des moments de plaisir et vécu
pour marie joëlle et jérôme devant
l'inconnu de cette pandémie
ce sera un jour à la fois pour éviter
aussi doivent de faire de goise de
l'anxiété n'a tenu mieux d'y aller jour
après jour semaine après semaine à ce
point de même intéressant que les écoles
s'organisent pour nous effectivement
pour nous permettre de faire de l'école
à la maison en attendant un peu comme
tout le monde maxime gaël et leurs
parents continue de s'adapter à cette
période
unique en son genre ici frédéric arnould
radio canada longueuil